[Music]
well I saw a really alarming newspaper
article just a week or so ago in which
it was some survey had had shown that
more than 50% of Republican of
self-identifying Republicans believed
that universities were bad for America
that believe that universities were
actually a negative harmful force in
American life that was I mean I'd never
I'd never seen any group of people
saying that before you know so that was
shocking and I do think this is not
unique to England added to it not to not
unique to America because also in
England there is a similar kind of
distrust of expertise you know and and
and you know in the brexit vote there
one of the things that came up over and
over again was a dislike of experts
telling you what to think you know and
and so somehow this this mistrust of
people who know things has has become I
mean
internationalized it's it's a it's it's
not just something about the American
right you know and it obviously it's
it's to somebody who has seen knowledge
as being a great virtue and at you know
and who has spent his life try to
accumulate little bits of it and and
somebody who thinks of knowledge as a
kind of beauty you know it's it's very
very discomforting to say the least just
have people who think of it as being
suspicious
you know because what's happening it
seems to me is a strange distortion of
the idea of the elite you know that
state to me if you're what you ask me
what's in elite I would think more about
the many many billionaires sitting in
the Trump administration you know that
years here's a government with more
super-rich people in it than has ever
been in any American government you know
and that government calls
college professors and journalists
elites you know we're not the ones with
private planes and golf courses of the
Bahamas you know very relatively few
novelists you know have these things and
the idea that we're the elite whereas
that group of you know that that kind of
point one of the 1% that that considers
itself to be in some way possessing the
common touch that sea just seems like a
absurd comic conversion of reality you
know them and I mean I think one of the
things we see at the moment and I tried
to in a way capture in in the novel is
this idea of a world turned upside down
you know in which in which things that
one thought of as being normal solid
believable descriptions of reality you
know are being stood on their head every
day and the idea of reality itself the
idea of truth is something verifiable
and objective all these things are being
inverted and and and I'm you know
knocked off their pedestals well I mean
you know there is a terrible thing which
writers sometimes say to each other
which is that the worse it is the better
it is
you know because I mean like when the
world is in a terrible condition there's
a lot to write about and I mean one
demonstration of this is that you know
the literature very often underground
literature the samizdat bitter of the
Soviet Union was of an extraordinary
quality you know when there was this
colossal adversary of Soviet
authoritarianism many many writers both
in fiction and nonfiction rose to that
challenge and and and and created
extraordinary work you know and and I
think it's not unfair to say that the
literature of the post Soviet Union the
literature of Russia since 1989 that
there is a sort of somewhat of a falling
off you know that it's it's not quite as
intense and extraordinary as that
earlier
that as that earlier work you know
because because of the lack of the
adversary you know it's in a way you
know and to put it another way so it
seems to me that spy fiction was
enormous ly damaged by the loss of the
Soviet Union because suddenly suddenly
who would this who were the enemy you
know and so I do think that in in times
like this which are very adversarial and
in which the question of the truth has
become so central no there's a big place
for art you know there's a really big
role for art and to speak up in such a
time and I think I think more or less
every writer I know in America is is
considering how best to respond to to
the to the place we find ourselves
including me and I mean this is you know
most of this book was written before
November the 8th I mean the the vast
bulk of it was finished before the
election and I mean I'm sorry to say
that I guessed right you know and that
that's to say that I always knew that if
things have gone another way that that
would have had to be some reshaping of
the of a part of the book but I don't
mean actually anyway there was I needed
to do a bit of reshaping because things
don't always turn out exactly as you
foresee but I wanted to try and capture
this strange moment you know and I'd
tell the truth that part of the novel is
very much background rather than
foreground you know so so the the actual
storyline of the book what happens to
the characters and and how they resolve
their particular dilemmas that would not
have been altered in any way if the
election had gone another way I mean
that's the story is the story but but
the context of the story the way in
which America developed in from you know
from the beginning of the Obama
administration to the present moment you
know what happened in that arc of time
that's that's the that's the context
against which the story takes place and
and there I had to I had to guess and
gamble a little bit and then and then
try and
fix things right up to the moment the
book went to the presses so that's more
or less you know there's a moment when
they take your fingers off the keyboard
they say we're printing the book today
so you you can't do anymore but until
that moment I was trying to fix things
[Music]